three
two one we're live awesome okay
pbd podcast episode 48 with tom
ellsworth biz doc as well as
matthew sapala money smart guy how are
you guys doing
great great to be here again second week
in a row yes
that's right that's right that just
means you're spending a lot of time in
florida what
do you what do you like about florida
you've been here now a couple of times
boca raton the land where you can just
spend stupid money
[Laughter]
everybody here is driving a g-wave
bentley
you know everybody here's got a yacht
that's correct i said the word yatchka i
went to high school
got a diploma that's how you spell it
like chair chapter
so tell us why you're wearing the red
shirt what's the rich shirt red shirts
friday
marine corps veteran represent the
military veteran community remember
everyone deployed we wear red on friday
and i remember uh pbd being deployed to
combat tours
and i always told myself listen lord i
must pray god if you just bring me back
home
away from this away from this i promise
i'm gonna do something
and uh i'm here and i'm gonna maximize
the opportunity i have to come back to
america live the american dream and make
the most of
the entrepreneurial dream and this is uh
remember every
everyone deployed because i know it's
like to be there in the
armpit of the world somewhere in a
foxhole and just appreciate america and
just freedom and
america america i love america man what
a special country okay
so uh mr thomas ellsworth how are you
doing i'm doing great
thank you for serving that i said that
to you more than once but thank you very
much for serving i have
your support uncle never came home from
vietnam and i
was very young at the time but i
appreciate every single one of you
that's some thing for our freedoms
take that on behalf of our brothers and
sisters out there thank you for
supporting by the way in the military
you don't pronounce it yak you pronounce
it destroyer
detroit you don't say yeah you say
destroy yeah i gotta destroy park
outside and
you know thanks to my house mine layer
cruisers missile guided crews
imagine going to a realtor and you're
having a serious conversation with your
realtor saying
will a destroyer fit here why i have one
i'd like to park it
right here and uh talking about ships
man there's something going on with a
ship in suez canal
egypt it's it's it's causing mayhem
around the world we got to talk about
that
we got to talk about gen z's getting
screwed by remote
remote work according to a microsoft
survey which we'll get into
facebook and amazon are now the top
lobbying spenders in the us
incoming amazon ceo andy jazzy picked
the close ally when he hired adam
selpski to run its 51 billion auto cloud
business
tesla now accepts bitcoin as payment
dahlia says the bitcoin community is
pissed off with dalio right now
sure he sees good probability that
bitcoin would get
outlawed citigroup ceo jane fraser calls
for free
zoom free fridays and new blank holidays
pandemic fatigue grows
wework is in talks to go public through
a spec
deal prince harry gets a job he sits on
a board now a
billion dollar silicon valley startup as
a senior executive i don't know if the
interview helped out or not but he
definitely got a job offer he accepted
it
royal caribbean just announced more
fully vaccinated cruises this year this
time in the mediterranean
intel investing 20 billion dollars in a
new chip making deal
planned as part of the turnaround plan
u.s
jobless claim falls to 684 000 people
fewer since pandemic
and then we got new york pot
legalization gets fast track on cuomo
lawmaker deal miami mayor wants the
federal government to help pay for elon
musk to tunnel
under his city which i'm sure bernie
sanders is very very excited about
biden's you know press conference that
he did first one he
talked about re-election he talked about
borders he talked about a lot of
different things
and uh you know bernie sanders gave some
love to trump i don't know if you guys
heard what bernie sanders said
tom did you hear what bernie said bernie
said can you pull up the tweet on what
bernie sanders said about trump being
banned from twitter
he says look he may be of this he may be
that he may be at this but i'm not
comfortable
about us banning a president
from being able to use twitter so think
about bernie sanders
a guy who is uh
let me read the topic what the headline
is kai if you can go all the way to the
top
bernie sanders against donald trump
twitter band tomorrow it could be
somebody else so even he
is saying that and then yesterday well
i'll translate somebody else
just put the word me meaning it could be
himself
yeah people with it what do you think
about bernie sanders defending donald
trump in this area i mean does bernie
want trump back on twitter no bernie
wants the
the whole heavy left liberal uh freedom
of speech even if it's inflammatory
because it could involve him that's what
i think he thinks what do you think
i mean that's this is cancer culture i
mean this is uh this is where we are
talking about the big dangers of
removing a freedom of speech even a
liberal left socialist can say hey
uh we understand the gravity of getting
deleted i can get deleted off twitter
um even they're admitting to this uh
this whole thing so i like to see this
uh continue to evolve yeah they say that
thing can be aimed at me too yes correct
what i like about this what i like about
this is the fact that
you know at any point it could flip to
somebody else but if there was
one person no one in the world would
have guessed that would come out
defending
trump on twitter bernie sanders no
nobody in the world would have expected
trump and maybe this says something
about bernie's character
here's what i think about bernie's
character i think bernie
likes a good fight whether you like him
or not if there's one thing about bernie
you gotta like
the guy's a guy who loves a good fight
and i think he misses fighting
who's his enemy right now
ted cruz it's now he's picking on elon
musk he's picking on jeff bezos he kind
of wants somebody to pick a fight on
and he needs trump back on yesterday
trump said he was
asked by laura ingram how does it feel
not being active on twitter and being
able to message on twitter
trump said i have to be honest with you
i prefer press releases
more than i do sending tweets because on
press releases i don't have a limit of
140 characters
and on press releases somebody looks
over my paper when i write it
and then they come out and they can't
say well you see he said this word he
said that word
he says i think it's working fantastic
every time i write a press release
everybody on twitter is talking about it
writing about it which is working
effectively
trump is like it's okay if we don't go
on twitter or not people we think about
trump potentially creating his own
social network we'll see what's going to
happen with that i mean if he
if he hires the right people the right
brains he's going to need the right
brains a lot of people
have tried to create a social uh media
network
i think the other thing he will need as
well is
he will need more than just republicans
and maggot to use it for it because it
would be another part
it would be a bigger parlor is what it
would be but he will need a little bit
of hollywood he would need a little bit
of music he would
need entertainment sports he would need
people there to want to participate
if not i don't know if a lot of people
from the other side are going to join
the social media network
it would only be to hear what he has to
say and criticize them and kind of go
from
there okay so you said you had strong
opinions about
legalization in new york uh uh pot
legalization gets fast track on cuomo
lawmaker deal so why don't we talk about
that let me go to page six here
on what happened with our buddy cuomo so
cuomo has not had the most exciting last
few weeks
now it comes out that new york is ready
to legalize recreational marijuana the
state would impose special pot taxes and
prepare to license
dispensaries under an agreement reached
by governor cuomo and legislative
leader the deal that legislative leader
brokered with cromwell would legalize
cannabis use for adults 21 years or not
years old and up and includes a 13 sales
tax
nine percent of which would go to the
state and four percent to localities let
me give that to you one more time
the deal would allow cannabis used to be
legal for 21 and up
13 sales tax on it nine goes to the
state
four percent goes to localities the
governor's office estimates that a legal
cannabis program could pull in 350
million dollars a year
once fully implemented assembly major
leader crystal people stoke said with
new jersey legalizing marijuana earlier
this year we are literally surrounded
graphically by other states that are
doing it
we just need to stay ahead of times
because we're new yorkers
we can walk and chew gum at the same
time we can speed this up
tom what are your thoughts on this uh i
think you should take away the word
cannabis
and put in alcohol or a lottery and then
insert the word the benefit will go to
the schools this is right out of the
playbook of every state in the nation
who understands when something's up and
i can tax it and i can take advantage of
it
and the wave of momentum is coming over
them they go with it and i think new
york's just going with it and
you know we're going to legalize alcohol
and we're going to get a tax on it and
the benefit will go to the school
do you think it's good or bad but the
question is do you think it's good about
because
let's face it i know a lot of people in
new york that would probably take
advantage
of this i'm sure a lot of people in new
york are going to go out there and say
okay great
350 million dollars is 350 million
dollars and
god knows new york needs tax money
because they lost a lot of people to
florida which means they need to find a
way to
generate that revenue back just a basic
question
is this a good strategy or is this a bad
strategy
i think it's good for new york well you
saw in chicago matt what did you see
yeah illinois
uh january 2020 is when illinois made
the sale
of cannabis illegal recreational wise
right before the pandemic go figure this
is illinois illinois yeah
just in time for a chill year exactly so
the 10 was the sales tax in illinois
generate half a billion dollars in
in revenue for illinois literally from
my office pb
two blocks just north of my office is a
recreational
uh marijuana lounge i mean you walk in
it's beautiful like a cigar like oh like
a cigar line you go in there and it's
just
it's beautiful it's it's well laid out
it's really nice uh
interior design i mean they decked it
out really yeah apparently it's a chain
what was the address people who like to
know what's
interesting right right 220 what's
what's actually name up what's the name
of the place uh it's uh what is it it's
called consume
it's called consume go figure consume
they got in illinois they got in
in michigan they got a bunch of
dispensaries uh there's a network
and it's literally two blocks away from
our office
and you know for me as as a parent it's
not only is it
a revenue generating illinois but it it
challenged me as a parent uh
you know my you know my my kids you know
dad everybody's smoking pot everybody
smoking pot
and then i i was i would discipline my
kids for this for for for
for marijuana use and the times i
disciplined them they didn't like it and
then
you know my kids now older you know my
son's 25 my twins are 19. they're like
oh well poppy
it's illegal now all the times you put
your discipline does
so yeah you know from from a parent to
stamp it's challenging because you have
to you know stick to your values and
principles even though
just because you could doesn't mean you
should uh type conversation with the
kids
but from a revenue generator for those
who are adult and those who know what to
do with the
recreational medicinal got a bunch of
veterans that
consume this medicinally that's what i'm
thinking what about what about youtube
going back to new york to answer the
question directly i think it's new york
is surrounded by states that have taken
the legislative approach
let's tax it let's continue forced a
little bit yeah they're kind of being
forced into the economic sanity
and uh stabilization and you know
people are gonna drive to connecticut
people can drive in new jersey or get a
buzz and drive home
you know one thing on this i still feel
very strongly about
no i mean breathalyzers are here to
help monitor drunk drivers and to keep
the rest of us safe and i think
we still i don't think anybody has
talked about figuring out how do you
judge
a real device to see that if someone's
impaired because i don't want people
driving impaired
even if it's legal and you know my kids
go to college and
they smoke if they do if they choose i'm
i
want to bring up good standards about
them about being intoxicated
you know but um wait what just happened
right there if you so if your kids
go to school and they drink and they
they they smoke weed and you want to
bring good standards i don't understand
that part now what i'm saying is i i
want to equip them with great judgment
skills so as adults if they choose to
in indulge you know i have my feelings
about what i hope they do and don't do
but
if they choose to you know i want them
to do so
legally ethically with care and
consideration for their fellow citizens
and i think on the marijuana side we
still don't have a good
breathalyzer for marijuana because
somebody's baked i think it's a good
idea they're not driving heavy
we really not have anything for that yet
is uh driving under the influence of
course you have your breathalyzers for
alcohol but do you have any
wetalizers for lack of a better term
that's the point
so there's nothing right now to find out
if somebody's smoking we didn't drive it
my understanding there is not a
consistent
approved 50-state device the way the
breathalyzer and the blood test at the
hospital for our question becomes do
they drive better or worse
that's the question what do they see do
they see new cars do you see like
unicorns do they see
lanes multi-dimensional lanes others
don't see i think we've i think we've
gone to acid path
and none of us are referencing anything
from any personal experience so
we have no clue yeah i mean there's a
lot of innocence at this table
okay so interesting you should never
operate a motor vehicle heavy equipment
or a marriage
we're going to see what's going to
happen here with illinois next one gen
z getting screwed by remote work
micro microsoft finds survey fines let's
read this here
a new study from microsoft found that
among more than 31 000 workers it
surveyed 73 percent said they want
remote work options to stay with 46
percent
stay saying the plan to move now that
they can work remotely
still 67 there's a bunch of percentages
here
67 percent said they want more in-person
work or collaboration too in short
we don't seem to know what we want is
what the article's saying however gen z
workers uh
born roughly between 1990s and 2010s
responded
to microsoft server survey generally by
saying they're more stressed and find
they're struggling more than their peers
they tend to be single since they're
younger leading them to be isolated
and since they're they're early in their
careers they don't have financial means
to create a good work space at home
if their employer won't pay for it and
they're not having
those in-person meetings that sometimes
help them land in career advancing
projects or even get
in good with the boss tom what do you
have to say about this i think there's
really something here because
you know last year america had to
respond and we had to make
zoom work and matt your business you
talk about how you guys
had a great year and you made zoom and
video conference work
within the lockdown requirements you're
under correct but what's interesting for
gen z with less experience
where's the coffee with the boss you can
look read their body language you can
see their insecurity or their confidence
and you can have that mentoring moment i
think that that's exactly what they're
talking about here
that those human interconnections are
lost
and it's not developing emotional
intelligence and the management skills
you know i just referenced what you did
with uh
you know your insurance agency sure did
you do you see it that way or am i crazy
but we
yes uh well last year we grew by 60 plus
percent
last year with zoom uh you know a lot of
people found
uh quicker accessibility to clientele uh
interviews hiring process recruiting
interviews but
we were locked down into that computer
all day it was all day all day all day
from sun up to sundown
the the volume of poems were able to
accomplish in an eight-hour 10-hour
12-hour day was was massive
uh i think it's interesting that
microsoft uh did this survey
don't they have the incentive for people
to use their microsoft teams you know
that if i find it
is this type of survey that's a very
good point zoom
zoom and yet they're saying people are
getting screwed my remote work
but i uh now that our offices are
starting to open back up what we've
missed what we've thoroughly missed was
the in-person
uh connections uh you gave us a magazine
to read last month is the harvard
business review about uh
how an office is a social anchor of a
company culture
and we just started opening offices back
up again uh
three weeks ago in illinois in our opera
office and people are feeling that
connection all over again
and in that article states that when
you're in person that's when you develop
a
develop teamwork trust commitment
camaraderie
you don't necessarily get that through
zoom
and i think you brought up a point
yesterday tom is that the gen z
worker is missing out on being around a
guy like you he's got experience three
comma tommy imagine being in office
you're hanging around three common
timing
bedroom being in an office with you pbd
the in-person connection they have with
somebody's there that they can be
basically uh an apprentice to they can
they can learn from
the wisdom that's around an in-person
environment
versus something you miss out on
remotely working yeah i i agree i
i think what they miss out on is
watching across the office seeing how
people interact
and there's a lot of i go back to
emotional intelligence i think that
that they lose that i don't think that
there's an opportunity to gain that
you know my own experience here at
valuetainment you know filming case
studies and so i film in the studio with
the
with the team that's shooting but then
this week being able to be
side by side with the editing team
talking to them you know got to know him
a little bit while we were
you know going over and edit you don't
do that on zoom you're just like
so the question becomes you got three
types of people you're dealing with
right if you want to get back into
opening again back up and come back to
the office you got the kind of person
who doesn't want to wear a mask could
care less about it they're like i don't
even
it's not something that scares me i'm
just you know it is what it is i have no
desire i'm not scared i can't wait for
us to work again i can't wait to be in a
physical office
i want this environment right the second
person you're dealing with
is a person that always follows the
rules and they just they're good
citizens which is what
you want me to wear a mask i'll wear a
mask you want me to do this they're just
more
the majority which is i'm gonna do what
i'm being told to do so one fights it
one follows the rules and the other one
is the extreme so the extreme is who
don't get close to me don't do this
don't do that
um hey don't touch me like like even um
yesterday when uh ted cruz was giving a
speech right
uh before he gets started one of the
reporters was like hey where's your mask
because i don't need a mask i'm speaking
to you right now it says no but where's
your mask he says well i just took the
test
i'm clean i've taken it i'm good i'm i'm
good i don't need to wear a mask
a vaccine today yeah he did so he says
he said the whole thing becomes right
those those three how do you make those
three work in an environment how do you
make the one that's kind of like
i i don't think it's a big deal what's
up tom how are you doing you know
just very friendly the guy in the middle
that's just following the guidelines and
the guy that's the extreme saying no
this is not safe this is not this like
making it extremely dramatic
the middle ones are obviously going to
be easy to deal with sure because here's
the guidelines here's what we're doing
it's the extremes of both ends that you
got to figure out a way to
reason with to make this going back to
office work
how do you make that happen tom i mean
you've been around for a while matt
you've been
running in office how are you doing i
was just in memphis last week
dealing with a couple of our guys uh uh
sabine rubinote in one office and edward
and jamie musgrove in the other office
and i'm i'm
they're excited to be amongst each other
you know they mentioned this is the
first time we've been together in a year
and all the excitement all camaraderie
and
the way they feel about each other
they've been built they've built that
yeah a relationship online working
together on a daily basis building the
insurance agency
and and the conversation became
uh uh nice to meet you uh are you a fist
bumper are you a handshaker you're
asking i'm asking
good and then and now people know i'm a
hugger i was like okay in the south i
guess they're a lot of hook
a lot of huggers no problem you know and
so i'm asking i said just
and i think it's another step pb you
just ask are you a fist bump or your
handshake what are you comfortable with
elbows
and some people are just elbows no
problem hey let's you know
yeah i can i can see that what do you
think of tom i think there's two things
the the first thing in all this is you
know you let the people know you know
what
if the civic is locked down if this is
here we're going to do
what the state is asking us to do um
and so we're going to you know take care
of that and then like there's somebody
there's an a great editor
that i work with kyle and he still feels
a little uncomfortable
so when you come to his cube he would
prefer to keep
he has a bandana he'd prefer to keep
wearing that but he's reasonable
he's very reasonable he gets his stuff
done he just says hey i'm just not
comfortable yet and i have an older
relative i guess he lives with true
says hey i get that so i give him the
space it's all cool
you you kind of elbow at a distance so i
think you show
care and consideration for the person's
viewpoint but you got to have a
reasonable
office environment where you're getting
things done and the inmates can't run
the asylum to say let's put up plexiglas
corridors everywhere
uh so i think you show care and
consideration and
you also show that you're complying with
the state and that
yeah i think you just guide people by
example and just show a little respect
for their particular future this leads
me to we work
which has a lot to do with what we're
talking about right here's we work a
company
that decides to go public through a spec
deal right we all know what we work is
we work is essentially what it's it's
office space right if you want a bunch
of businesses coming together
and we work in the same office space
together which by the way brilliant idea
they were killing it i mean everybody
was talking about it
sort of a cool version of regis for the
month
exactly right they get old regions old
old buildings that they would never do
yeah exactly so the office sharing
startup plans for its high profile ipo
imploded spectacularly in october 2019
due to widespread
criticism over its business model and
its founder adam newman's management
style
we work at hell talks with at least
three blank check firm spanx
over the past two months cautioning that
the current talks could fall apart we
have specs approaching on a weekly basis
we work executive chairman marcelo clark
said who used to be with sprint
wework was valued at 47 billion dollars
in 2019
but saw its valuation plummet to roughly
8 billion
after softbank was forced to extend the
life-saving financing lifeline
at wework so the part everybody has to
realize is even before the pandemic
these guys were having problems they
fired out of newman
they laid off 2 400 employees they lost
billions of dollars and then comes
coronavirus they get crushed
tom do you think these guys can recover
from it and be a business model that's
profitable
that people would want to invest in
i i don't know i mean marcelo clark has
basically done more
stabilization than innovation he
stabilized things
and they're trying to get out with the
story um
but you know what's really interesting i
think it the whole thing they're waiting
for people to go back from
work from home to use office again
because wework was about
hey if you step back and look at wework
they were for gen z the open lobby
everybody gets to hang out together
you know there's a word for that in
covit it's called super spreader
so i i don't know they got to convince
people that that business model is going
to work and that businesses are going to
come back and want
open areas where people can hang out by
the coffee machine learn from each other
and each
business have their own little private
idaho in there but i i think
softbank i mean softbank that 47 million
things softbank hit hard wall
you know that was not fun and so i think
they want to get out and they almost
have to get out to the market
so they can you know put this money in
the bank but
they got to prove to everybody there's a
real business there would you invest in
wework right now
nope like are you buy sell hold
neutral i've got great respect for soft
bank but i think they're in a very hard
place
why are they doing it though these are
smart people why are they getting into
it
put your hat on and say what
alternatives do they have right
they need capital to run this this is
continuing to run at a loss
even before the pandemic so how can
rents be up that they're actually making
a buck
is this if a if soft bank is
deciding to do something like this is
this a good sign for everybody else to
say
that if a company like softbank views
everything going back to normal if
they're risking money like this to
invest into a company
that's a mess like wework is because of
what happened in 2019 and the fact that
pandemic crushed them
i'm not even talking about the issues
prior to on the adam newman's management
style
let's set that aside i'm just talking
about the consequences of what kovit did
to wework absolutely if they're
investing are they
indirectly saying we feel the future
looks bright everything's going to go
back to normal
i i for me this is this if you're going
to ask me to invest in
i know whim am i putting my retirement
savings that i i'm knowing that it needs
to be there when i retire no i'm not
doing am i putting a little bit of my
money toward
of course i would because i believe in
the the
we work uh office sharing uh platform
uh we we've got a bunch in uh in
downtown chicago um at the
merchandise mart and uh uh just a bunch
of
incubating um entrepreneurs are there i
think the
the the attraction back again of again
back to the connection
because you can't really connect with
people on zoom and i think if you're
gonna connect uh uh
with other entrepreneurs of people that
are are incubating too as well in that
phase of their business
a wework type of operation grows um they
got uh they got some spacks uh
approaching them
you know you know the the type of money
is that's being thrown in this direction
i take a whim at it um if i'm incubating
entrepreneur
today i'd be looking for a weworks uh
type of
office sharing platform to start my
business so yeah interesting if you if
you're watching this i'm actually
curious right now okay let's take a look
at this we got 217 thumbs up kai i don't
know if you're seeing it
we got 217 thumbs up right now no thumbs
down by the way appreciate the love if
you're with us and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
and some of you that think you already
are subscribed this is a different
channel it's a pbd podcast channel so
click that subscribe button and the
notification but i got a question for
you i got a question for you
thumbs up if you are fully comfortable
going back to work and being around
others
you know where you know how it was in
2019 are you like i cannot
wait to go to a fully environment thumbs
down
if you're saying it's reckless we're
starting way too early we should take
our time so
smash thumbs up if you say yes we got to
get back to work and being around each
other thumbs down if you don't so we
have 217
and zero i'm actually curious to know
what happens to it so far
uh uh voting with that most people are
saying they want to get back to work do
you see that only two people
so far have said no most of the world
not what the media tells you
not what the you know focus groups of a
certain
niche group of people tell you right by
the way 321 to 1.
think about that that means 104 people
voted thumbs up
one person said i don't want to go back
to work so to the person that said you
don't want to go back to work do you
mind commenting below and saying
why okay now we went to five let us know
why
you're uncomfortable of going back is it
the fear of
you know uh kovit being contagious is it
uh uh you know what if i get sick and
what's happening right now with
different schools or different places
and you know it's the spread that's
taking place in different places
it's happening right now we had a
conversation with a couple of schools
that are going through it in texas
that this is taking place we experience
it ourselves
or or is it just something where the
tipping point is
i just don't want to work in an
environment anymore because a part of
this i know certain people who are
introverts
that they would love to work from home
for the rest of their lives exactly they
would love to not be around other people
they would love so
how much of this is revealing
the extroverts and the introverts okay
yeah how much of this is revealing
who has always wanted to work from home
and they never wanted to be around
others they would much rather do their
work and not go to a work environment
and how much of it is you know i'm just
scared wanting to go back
i'm curious i've asked you in many many
conversations uh you know because you
know you get
uh distracted all the time by all these
different ways to make money online
all these different ways to do
e-commerce many different ways to run a
business from
behind the computer the four-hour work
week of person right
you too can run an amazon drop ship
business
seven months and so i've i asked you and
and if you could
share with the viewers and listeners
here what your answer was to me because
um because i asked you can we really run
an insurance operation grow an insurance
operation
or any business operation that requires
people to be working together
with something that sustains and lasts
and creates generational wealth
could we do this from behind a computer
and your answer to me was
if you know if you want to build
something that lasts man i think you
need to
you need to be around and build
something together cohesively as a team
in an environment can you continue
i always i always battle with one thing
let me tell you what it is i remember
one time you know uh
reading an article about you know here's
what's the mistake of
millennials and here's how they are and
here's the gen ed he's just talking
about the younger generation all the
problems that they have
but the sentence it ended with this is
time magazine
the sentence it ended with was
but then again if you are complaining
about millennials
maybe it's because you're getting older
okay because
every generation told us that
these men men like elvis presley who are
shaking their hips
you know this is not good for our kids
and our daughters they should not see a
man
move his hips the way he does this is
not appropriate it's not the
conservative thing
to do elvis presley was you know moving
his hips and my girls were going crazy
yeah that's right right my music makes
me move so
so you got you got that so the older
generation you know i'm i'm not 42
which means i'm young enough to connect
to the 20 30 year olds but i'm
yeah i'm young enough to connect to uh
uh the 20 to 30 but also at the same
time old enough where it's 50 years
you know just 10 years and 60 is right
there it's not like you know when i was
20 the
today 60 year olds were 40 when i was 30
they were 50 when i'm 42 they're 60
right so
we're right in the middle so for us to
say you know
the zoom model is the only way to go is
the old school model
that also means maybe we're not adapting
with the time right it also means maybe
we're getting too old and we're not
willing to
adjust and see what the directions are
maybe the younger generation's got
something to teach us
and we have to realize this is something
that is going to be here to stay but at
the same time
at the same time at the same time
how many times have you gone to
someone's
house where the kid has been what's the
word i'm looking for
where they are isolated isolated from
everybody their entire lives because the
parents are so paranoid and i'm not even
talking about covet
i'm just talking about parents who
hardcore isolate their kids
from everything and you talk to the kid
how are you good
how's your day today good so
what's your favorite thing to do video
games
so i don't know yeah i don't know right
you see right so
so i'm like dude like where's the soul
man
let me let me like where's the conflict
where's where's so how do you get that
the only way you get that is what to be
around other people you know
what makes us different from animals is
we can respond we can communicate we
have a way of talking to each other we
can create we can
work together as a community so i think
both is needed and i'm kind of glad
microsoft is doing the survey by the way
i love when companies do a survey
that some parts of the survey it
contradicts their own business model
and for these guys to own what they have
to say hey we got to kind of get back to
work
it makes sense but we we will not know
the consequences of the way we handle
covid
and the isolation it'll take a minimum a
decade
or two to see it because a six-year-old
that was going to school is going to be
26 one day
16 and 10 years you ain't going to know
what this is going to do to him right
now
is he going to make a full recovery is
he not that's that's the one part we
don't know someone no matter what
anybody says experts any doctor anybody
says
none of us know what is really going to
happen
10 years from now the whole thing with
the vaccine when i talk to certain
people that don't want to take it
like yesterday one of our friends jose
he goes to the hotel and she says uh
this 22 year old
girl is like i can't wait to take the
vaccine and then everything can get
sir please be careful touching that you
know you don't want to get sick
and then jose asked the lady says can i
ask you a question says yeah
so what's in the vaccine she says well i
think it's
all good stuff and she says he says
when you eat do you not look at the
label on what's in it yeah
don't you think it's a good idea for you
to also know what's in the vaccine
i guess that makes sense well we don't
know what's in the vaccine
so so the people that are uncomfortable
with the vaccine and i know we're making
a big push right now you
bite and talked about yesterday going to
200 million right he's already done 100.
he wants 200 million in the first 100
days
100 million in the first 85 days the
challenge with us is
we also don't know what's going to
happen with this vaccine side effects
for decades you're not going to know
what's going on there's some side
effects that could be a decade two days
about the military shots we took when
we're in look what happened to us
you know so we have no idea what those
shots were that we took so
we are not really going to know the side
effect of the level of isolation and
people working from home
for for quite some time kids and some
adults tom do you have any feedback on
this
yeah i do i think uh i think you make
some great points and
right now i look at it like this it's
not binary but the news media looking
for the story
kind of treats it as binary like all
work from home or not and i think what
happened is
business found a way to make it work and
make it work profitably
and we found certain parts of business
that like you know
coders could be working remotely still
on a team be very effective
but the human interaction and the
culture of the business can't be
communicated over zoom
and so i i think it's not binary and i
think one of the things we're going to
find out later
to your point we're all going to look
back at that and find out that maybe
culture
and the humanness is lost uh even though
oh my coding worked well i made a profit
that year everything got done
i i don't think we're going to know for
about 10 years we're going to look back
and we're going to see
wow did we lose that we lose that
interconnection
you know long before i'll tell you
something long before
you know gofundmes if somebody
of um that that didn't make as much as
other people lost a relative or
something
we did go fund me we took collections in
the office we said wow you know this
around the head
yeah this this is an only child who's
going to be responsible for burying
their uncle and has got all this
this stuff so we would pass the hat and
then have like
hr quietly say your co-workers have
risen up
to kind of help you out here we did a
good that is a cultural
moment for that person and there's a lot
of that stuff i think is going to be
lost and to your point i think it is
going to be 10 years
what do you think you look at your
insurance agency now and a year ago
where do you think the impact is i mean
i'm i'm thinking where i
got stuck on in terms of the vaccine was
if if sheena was pregnant today
would i trust her to take the vaccine
and my answer is no
i agree it went out it went out so
quickly what was it three months of
testing
so how do they find willing pregnant
women
to do a true test across the
developmental nine-month flow of a child
to see with micro doses to see if
something's up yeah 100
pb what do you think uh i i we will find
out here in the next few years
on what's going to happen we're going to
find out what's going to happen next few
years i think one thing i do bank on
is the ability for human beings to adapt
and some adapt faster some some adapt
slower
those who adapt slower typically are led
and respond to who those who adapt
faster similar to what happened in
sports
everybody responded to what dana white
did everybody's shutting stuff down dana
white said we're going on an island then
they said well maybe we got to do it and
then orlando opened up and they said
we're going to do the bubble basketball
so people so there's typically one
person that goes out there and does it
and he's a risk he's got the biggest
risk to take because if he screws up
everyone's going to say i told you not
to do it
but he's also got the highest potential
of being a hero because if he wins
everybody says damn he's smart look what
he did
let's follow his suit so we're going to
see right there's going to be companies
that are going to open up and they're
going to get hard
core criticism from the marketplace
and then there's going to be companies
that are not going to open up that
they're going to get what
hardcore support and empathetic oh my
gosh you're so wonderful for doing what
you're doing
one of them is going to be a hero and
one of them is not
in the next year or two years we're
going to look at one and we're going to
say wow good for them well they know
what
those guys were too scared or vice versa
we'll see what's going to be happening
so time will tell
i don't think any one of us can see
what's going to happen right now but i
want to go to some of the people here
that
commented and aaron delgado gave 20 and
he said the following
he said drunk drivers blow through stop
sign
stoned drivers wait for them to turn
green
nicole nicole cerino gave 10 bucks she
said she wants to see tulsi gabbard and
dave
went on to discuss pat's tax idea for
california that was by far my favorite
discussion ever
roll tide nicole why don't you go on
twitter and tweet at both of them with
my handle
and then we'll see if the audience wants
to see it or not and what kind of
attraction we'll get
uh uh odora noel zenitman gave 10 bucks
gen z's
need to get into real hard working jobs
not remote wishy-washy jobs unless it's
straight up code writing
this generation has it's way too easy
and our least appreciative of honest
hard work then we have another person
here reuben
zuvalonav said good morning please
interview your george friedman and
geopolitical futures it will be on the
top of uh
uh one of the top interviews for us
versus china make a note of that and
we'll take a look and let you know how
that goes then we have 50-year journey
he said it's not he gave 20
it's not about work more than it is
about social aspect we are mostly social
by nature
a we works will allow for that without
the feeling
of a slave office feeling plus it gets
rid of the business liability for covet
very interesting
very interesting and then we have good
mother who said the following she gave
10 bucks
and she said all the people i know
personally who want to stay home
are female all the people i know who
want to stay home are female
i would be curious to go a little deeper
there with data to find out if majority
of the people that want
to work from home are female i don't
know maybe that's her reality her circle
that could be her reality her circle but
if somebody could do that data to pull
it up it'd be a very interesting
research
to discuss so one of the folks on
twitter if you got any questions that
you want us to address if you go on
twitter
and tweet with pbd podcast pbd podcast
we will address the uh some of the
questions that you may have
one of the guys here asked about bitcoin
danio
mateo said nfts and bitcoins are
as the global reserve currency well
before we go into the global reserve
currency
why don't we talk about what ray dalio
said about bitcoin
being outlawed here's what ray dalio had
to say
about bitcoins being outlawed the
founder of the founder the founder of
the 150 billion dollar hedge fund
bridgewater associate the world's
largest
made a case that there's a good
probability bitcoin could be outlawed
similar to when the u.s government made
it illegal to
privately own gold as dahlia points out
in his upcoming book the changing world
order the gold
reserve act of 1934 made it illegal for
individuals to own gold because
government leaders didn't want to
compete
they don't want gold to compete with
money and credit as a storehold of
wealth
something similar would happen with
bitcoin which has searched against a
backdrop of a high level of debt
low interest rates a lot of liquidity
and stimulus and investors seeking
alternative to bonds and currencies
every country here's what he says every
country
treasury treasures it's monopoly on
controlling the supply and demand
very powerful statement i want to read
that again every country
treasures its monopoly on controlling
the supply and demand sure they don't
want other monies to be operating or
competing
because things can get out of control so
i think
that it would be very likely that you
will have it under a certain set of
circumstances
outlawed the way gold was outlawed
thoughts max apollo well gold was
outlawed in 1933
and uh for in terms of holding
possession of actual physical gold
and then uh was a gerald ford 1974
that said okay can have it back it they
repealed it is this
potentially something that bitcoin can
be outlawed temporarily
for that 30-40 year process until the
government can figure out what type of
role that bitcoin could play in their
economy i've always said this from the
beginning my position
in the beginning bitcoin sounds cool it
sounds very good but there's a
difference in
in my investing world of intrinsic value
and imputed value
intrinsic value i mean there's an actual
asset that's actually generating
value behind the company imputed value
is what you think it's worth
for me as an investor and me not coming
from any money
uh driving a bus as a kid and now in
outstanding make money doesn't mean i'm
frivolous with money just throw money at
things
for me it's hard for me to personally
bank on again i won't put my retirement
savings here money that you know needs
to be there
into something that you know again i'm
not giving financial advice
but uh i uh i'm saying that for
something that is imputed it's kind of
hard to see
the government saying we're going to
release control
of the number one way to control
american citizens into something
that's uh decentralized it's it's only
one government regulation away
from from bitcoin being outlawed and and
the opportunity being stripped away from
it
temporarily curious if you're watching
this if you're watching this comment
below do you think
ray dalio is right and there's gonna be
some kind of a
you know a bitcoin being outlawed or
controlled by the government tom what
are your thoughts
well i think ray's not trying to make a
controversy here i think he's really
looking at a historical case study
because the governments they control the
interest rates they control the money
supply
m1 m2 and they're out there want to
have the knobs of the economy and they
don't want a secondary
um you know currency or value under
there that's why the whole thing
happened from the gold reserve act in
1934.
so i i don't think ray is trying to be
controversial but i i think that the
governments with the fiat currencies and
fiat currency
meaning currencies that are not backed
up by gold or silver they're just
you know the you know the the implied
trading value at that at that moment as
compared to other currencies
they don't want to they don't want to
lose that because they lose control of
the actual
you know economy itself in their
secondary economies there is a case
study on this and it is russia
and the joke during the reagan
administration with russia
is like hey russia can come to the
monetary
trading system once they have a currency
of defined value that can be traded
against other currencies
remember the ruble was a joke at the
time remember that
people said what are you talking about
they do have a currency that trades
against other currencies
it says it's green it's got pictures of
u.s presidents on it
and so the joke was that it was u.s
currency was the hard currency in russia
that the russians would actively
conduct commerce on and that flipped out
you know the russian government
so the government's and there's there's
your case study there forget about
communism forget about things
but the russian government didn't want
the u.s dollar to be
you know this underground currency and
they put a lot of steps in try to
control that and it failed but the
governments don't want to give up that
control man
so so go ahead pewdie what do you think
i mean dalio's got a vested interest to
outlaw
bitcoin i mean he's a fiat currency guy
he he is a fiat currency guy but that's
my question for you about bitcoin okay
kyle i want you to think about this as
well from a young standpoint on what you
would say about this
so what is more necessary
and and beneficial selfishly for the
government so think like a politician
think you are biden think you are janet
yellen
who janet yellen's been one of the
biggest proponents of trying to control
bitcoin she's not a bitcoin person she's
not necessarily a pro bitcoin person
right
taking elizabeth warren is elizabeth
warren pro bitcoin
i don't know she's a regulation she's a
regulation person right if you look at a
a biden a elizabeth warren a bernie
sanders
here's what's the weirdest things that's
happened when i talk to people the guy
that sold that nft can you pull up nft
underways uh every days he just did a
nice one of elon musk yesterday by the
way i don't know if you saw that on a
pretty sick one he did yesterday of uh
so so he sold this for 69 million
dollars
i asked the question in the interview i
asked the question in the interview
uh tom you've heard about this the every
day it's 5 000 days
every day he designed one and then he
put it together as a college very
prolific people
people he's phenomenal right so him and
i spoke last week mike
and i asked the question when he did the
the auction at christie's
and christie's you know christie's
auction house they do bigger things they
do artwork they do
stuff that's physical he said there were
33 bidders
active bidders the last hour of the item
it's like at 14 million ended up selling
for
69 million i asked the question i said
14 million 33 bidders he said yeah
i said out of those 33 bidders how many
of them are bitcoin
how many of them are bitcoin
millionaires he said all of them they're
all bitcoin crypto cryptocurrency people
so which means what every once in a
while
you know something comes in where
most people don't take advantage of it
okay where an average
regular joe who is a little bit
you know different weird people call
them crazy people call them out of the
ordinary
ends up buying into it and they put a
thousand dollars in bitcoin when it was
nothing
a quarter a dollar two bucks 10 bucks 30
bucks whatever it is
they put 10 000 into it now they're
millionaires
now they have money some of them have
real money
some of them have a few hundred million
dollars a few of them are billionaire
crypto
billionaires that are out there right
okay
what happens when people are popping out
being billionaires and millionaires
in an industry that not many people
looked at and trusted and there was a
community that was doing
i don't know if there's gonna maybe
there's gonna be some stuff that's going
on that's shady
now they have that money okay so how
much money was being made selling
cocaine
years ago and i'm not making a
comparison the only reason i'm saying
this i'm going to a place with this
how much money is cocaine per year how
much money is
pot per year how big of a business is it
how much money was
alcohol when bootleggers used to make
money how much money is it right
is the government more concerned about
control and the worry of currency
manipulation with bitcoin
or is the government more concerned
about collecting taxes
because if you do over regulate crypto
or bitcoin or any of that
then where do you collect the taxes from
all these people that are making
billions of dollars that's revenue going
back to the government
so what's more important to the us
government the control of the currency
to not be able to manipulate our current
fiat currency
or the ability to collect more taxes and
add a tax to it so again let me let me
go a little deeper so this makes sense
to you
so maybe there is no regulation but
maybe there's a bitcoin tax
maybe they're saying we're not going to
regulate it but we're going to add a 15
like you know the same thing they said
the we tax in
new york 13 9 goes to the state 4 goes
to the localities
what if there is a tax on bitcoin rather
than a regulation
is the government thinking revenue or is
the government thinking control
what are your thoughts i think control
is taxation i think if you're going to
control it because because you want to
tax it and
if you can tax it you can find a way to
manipulate i think it's both pbd
great point you know when russell ochong
the nfl players had paid
half of my 13 million dollar in bits
bitcoin i mean
so how do you tax now half of a salary
when the other half of the sale it's
easy 40
whopped you know just chopped right off
to the uh to the income taxes
but the other half of his salary went
from 6.5 to 8.5 10.
you can't tax it because it's it's
bitcoin so i think it's both pvd
tom i i i think the conservative side of
government
wants uh reasonable controls
and i think the highly liberal side of
government wants to tax everything
with controls so i think it's a little
bit of both and i think the
you know the central banks and the money
policy people
they want the control back because they
control the world's you know financial
system
if you're if you and i you've been in
the world of dealing with investors for
a long time
right an investor if the if you
represent an investor and he brings in
the money okay
what are some ways investors control the
entrepreneur
what are some ways if you were to tell
us i know it i'm just hearing from you
so the audience can
what are some ways the investor says
i'll give you this 5 million i'll give
you this 50 million but
these are the controls what are some
ways the investor controls the
entrepreneur
the most common thing that people find
with venture investment or private
equity investment is what's called the
preferred position they have what's
called preferred stock
so they get to approve every transaction
over x
and then there's the operating committee
you have you have your boards and they
get a couple board seats so now they got
a certain number of boards so they put
these control that in exchange for my
money
i get these controls because you're a
nice entrepreneur i want to make a buck
on you we all want to make a buck on
this
but we're going to be on your board
controlling these things
and then you can't spend or do things
beyond a certain limit
here or bad things happen and so they
they put controls around their money
and how many controls are there like let
me let me
maybe you're not going as deep as it can
be so one is preferred
the other one is voting control correct
the other one is how much money you can
pay for yourself for salary
sure the other one is how much money you
can spend in one transaction so if
you're gonna do anything anything that
you're gonna spend over fifty thousand
dollars you need our approval a hundred
thousand dollars half a million dollars
a million dollars whatever
how much uh the profit money is a bonus
for executives versus a dividend
back to them to everybody that they
participate in there is so many
different ways that they create controls
right correct here's a question for you
historically
what are some ways the us government can
impose
controls on bitcoin taxation being one
of them
what are other creative ways that a
janet yellen
or a biden administration can create
controls on
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
wow you're spooked yeah the guy who's
so so so all i'm asking is there are so
many creative ways
what is the way what are they going to
do to create controls
you know attacks being one of them
regulation being another one
you know uh uh how much uh a
a like you know how um remember when the
gme the gamestop stock went up and then
all of a sudden they said what no more
activity no more activity is there a
lid to be put on it on how much it can
go can they price it themselves
you know one controller is coming and
saying hey gold is worth what was the
dollar amount back in 1934 when it was
it goes were 30 to
29 34 dollars you remember what the
number was 36
some number like that where they said
here they dictate
what it's worth so can what if they come
out and they say
we're gonna regulate you say bitcoins
worth fifty thousand dollars per
we're gonna put a number on it bitcoin
is worth ten thousand dollars per
like i'm not saying that's what they're
going to do all i'm asking is
you have to anticipate that regulators
think very differently than freedom
libertarian leave me alone entrepreneurs
innovators so
we have the sec and the market controls
right okay and the sec influences used
to be
the amex used to be chicago board of
options you had all these markets out
there where you could buy and sell
stuff whether it's fruit and livestock
futures or
a share of stock or an option on stock
and the sec has got things in there
about
volatility and what's called the circuit
breakers if the circuit breakers trip
they suspend trading on things
so they can put tight controls in there
that are deemed to
protect the investor robin hood remember
limited how many you could trade a
certain day
sec could step in and do simple things
like that there's a lot of ways that
they could control
the momentum the amount and go back to
the uh
it's not even a hundred years ago the
federal reserve act 1934 of
how much you can own i just thought
about something
the easiest way to to control and
manipulate it is to increase if you want
to pay for
something we can hear you if they want
to pay for something in cash or credit
cards at this price but if they want
paying bitcoin is this price
right yeah the other part is like look
what happened with the industry you and
i are part of right
you got a joseph kennedy who gets
recruited by a roosevelt to come in and
try to figure out the stock market
manipulation and
joseph kennedy calls a meeting
apparently that says hey everybody needs
to come to new york who's selling stocks
and people didn't show up it's like wait
a minute you better listen to me and
show up they didn't show up so he says
you know what
the only way you can sell stocks moving
forward is you have to pass a license
call the series seven
then everybody ended up showing up they
said the only way you can sell it you
have to fingerprint because back then
there were caches being handled
so they came and do finger we're doing
fingerprinting till today we don't even
touch cash we don't even know why we're
doing fingerprinting till today right
so there's an element of licensing
there's an element of you know
those are the things like how all of
they're pretty creative when they come
out with regulation
kai do you have something in mind you
want to share with us yeah no so i think
i think the biggest thing for them also
now that uh essentially because bitcoin
you keep in a wallet right that wallet
essentially the government really
doesn't have access to they don't know
how much is in there
depending on how much you've earned if
you buy in low
you sell high kind of this that and the
others i think a big a big part of it is
that that money can sit in the wallet
and you're not paying any capital gains
or anything of that kind
uh so now that say tesla is allowing you
to buy a bitcoin right
or buy it yeah with bitcoin i think
that's the only place where
government realistically can then go in
and take a piece of the pie
because now they can see oh you have
that you're trading that value
so then they have to come in with some
sort of tax there because if not
the bitcoin can just sit in a wallet and
that money can store that money can stay
there it can grow
yadda yadda yadda or the other way is
when you then
put that money from you the bitcoin into
your bank then it's kind of like oh
suddenly you have 40 million here what's
going on mr xyz
um so for regulation or just purposes of
taxes
i think that they're gonna have to find
a way to tax spending money with bitcoin
on buying something
in that transaction you have to find a
way to kind of get a piece of the pie
there
i remember when uh you're right kai i
remember when there's a point in time
you can buy something on amazon or ebay
without having paid tax on it
there's no there's no tax on it now
that's right now they're tax that's
right
so this is just another evolution can
they stop bitcoin i don't think they can
but they can find a way to
tax it yeah well there was also that you
long ago you could commit several wire
transactions and you could effectively
obfuscate what you were doing with money
and then the federal government said it
okay
to control it they forced the banks to
be the reporting agency and be
not really the cop of the reporting
agency so what's the limit
on a wire transaction now where the bank
has to turn in your social security
number and the wire transaction
ten grand right a deposit of ten
thousand dollars in a bank the banks
have to report it correct
so now who's not so now the government's
got the okay in exchange for fdic
insurance
you have to and all these other benefits
of connecting the money supply and the
overnight borrowing rate for all the
banks
now you have to tell us every time
there's a transaction of over two ten
thousand dollars good point
so now they're collecting all the
information so they can come back to you
on an audit and say matt you had all
these wires going back and forth you can
no longer hide where your money's coming
going from
was this income or is the savings to
check in what was going on here
and they they know it so there's a lot
of other controls that go in there
that was one of the first we talk about
the government having too much data on
us and things like this
that was a data gold mine for the irs
auditors now they had the banks
recording and reporting every ten
thousand dollars
so banks would have fdi say the bank was
to go in the default the banks have fdic
if if uh if uh you know a brokerage went
you know went to default
you'd have the sipc what would it be for
crypto would be for bitcoin there is
none
well there wasn't those until they
needed them was that correct until
people started losing a lot of money
that
there it is here's the protection so so
you're saying if
all of a sudden a lot of people lose
money and there's a dramatic drop off
then we may have an sipc type of thing
set up correct
got it interesting that's the regulation
to protect the consumer
there'll be a crisis and government will
say never let a good crisis go to waste
and in the name of protecting us there
will be regulations and systems put in
place
we got homeland security protecting us
as we go on airplanes
now that didn't exist right we had a
crisis and
now we have a new government agency as
ronald reagan said
there's never anything so permanent as a
temporary government program it's
receipt bills and stop signs the stop
lights came from because somebody got
into a
gun to erect cost people their lives
okay crypto right now is at fifty three
thousand dollars right crypto right now
is that fifty three thousand dollars
what's more likely crypto going to a
million or crypto going to ten thousand
oh good one
i'm the i'm the optimist i'm going i'm
going to a million
million you you wait a minute you think
ten thousand
so you could it come back to 10 000 on a
cell spike a spike of selling momentum
that drives the price down
sure it could but the limited supply of
crypto
is like limited supply of real estate in
malibu
the way that works that limited supply
ensures scarcity
so i think there is actually yeah could
it touch 10 grand
on on a trading blip we had so many
people trading on a certain day
sure but i think long term it's more
likely that it continues to trend to a
million
very very interesting by the way if you
like the exchange and the ideas we had
on the bitcoin side
uh hit that subscribe button and the
notification button even if you think
you're subscribed believe me
many of you are not this is not
valuetainment this is pbd podcast
click on that subscribe button next
topic to get into
is biden's press conference did you guys
have a chance to listen to biden's
press conference some of it i confess i
didn't dive in deep
so you know from what you heard you know
the topics that they had you know i'll
go to page six so part of it was
his re-election uh uh i watched the
whole thing
and it was pretty interesting seeing
what was said because there was one side
that they said he was horrible
and there was one side that said he this
the greatest maybe the goat of president
from what he did so biden intends to run
for re-election president biden the
oldest person to be sworn into office 78
years old said he
intends to run for re-election ask the
vice president kamala harris would be on
the ticket he said i would fully expect
that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner biden said former president
donald trump has filed for re-election
uh uh early in his presidency uh
had filed for re-election not has filed
for re-election had filed for
reelection early in his presidency
because he needed to biden also said oh
god i miss him with a laugh
asked if he expected to run against
donald trump was 74 years old biden said
oh come on i don't even think about that
i have no idea
biden then blamed trump for all the
border issues which will
uh he got into you know pretty
aggressively i think
most the covet topic lasted
two minutes of the entire thing meaning
media is not even worried about
the covet situation you have to know
that media only asks whatever area you
have problems with
so if the media didn't ask any questions
about covet that means they're over it
listen it's good we're going back 100
million 200 million
you know but but they spend a lot of
time
on immigration okay under pressure over
the flow of immigrants migrants of the
southern border
biden took aim at his pr predecessor
saying that the president trump
eliminated funding and
resources for the border biden said what
we're doing now is attempting to rebuild
we're building up the capacity that
should have been maintained
and built upon and trump dismantled it
it's going to take time
unaccompanied miners are crossing
illegally each day
in record numbers with total uh crossing
this year on pace to hit a two-decade
high
facing growing bipartisan pressure the
administration is ramping up its
diplomatic efforts and racing to find
more shelter space to house children as
it tries to tackle
surge of asylum seekers without adopting
the aggressive deterrent strategies of
previous administration so
you know couple things were asked which
was interesting he said we're about to
put 5 000
beds in fort bliss for people the
migrant kids that are coming here people
are coming here from texas
and then the question was asked by uh uh
one two ladies one lady says look you
know
your campaign was around how noble of a
man you are and how amazing of a man you
are
and do you think more immigrants are
coming to america
because they're seeing you be more
reasonable
and so they're wanting to come to
america versus when trump was here they
felt like they're going to send their
kids back
so they didn't send their kids do you
see a spike in more parents
wanting to send their kids here because
you're not sending them back okay
and his ins his response was interesting
he said
he said no i don't see any difference
there he says and if it was because i'm
nice i don't think people are sending
their kids more here because i'm nice
this is an issue that's been going on
for quite some time and it's not
something that i have any issues with
then another lady asked the question
said
a lady from honduras sent her a son
nine-year-old son
to come and cross the border because she
felt
you again wouldn't send him send him
back
he would let him come to america uh and
that message is coming across where more
parents are
taking their savings and they're given
to coyote to bring
the kids to america and he says no i'm
not that's not the case either
you know if they do come we're going to
do our best and another person asked and
said
well how come we can't see anything can
we see what's going on and
what's the plan down there he says i
don't intend to go down there myself
because i don't want the attention to be
taken off what the people are doing
i don't want to go there with secret
service which you know trump would have
been there in a heartbeat
and so would have obama so what if other
people would have been their heartbeat
and he says i'm not intending on going
out there
i'm going to send my troops my people to
go out there and see what's going on and
come back
ted cruz gets on and he gives a speech
he says
never has there been a president not
obama not
trump not clinton not bush who didn't
allow media to go to the borders to see
how these kids
are being treated there's a big uh you
know
a spread of covet right now going on so
biden's
using that as an uh as a way of saying
well we don't want people to go out
there because there's a big outbreak we
don't want a lot of the media to get
coveted
so we're trying to protect you anyways
there was a lot of different things that
was talked about but they were hitting
them
you know hitting them very strongly on
the immigration part
tom do you have any thoughts on the
how immigration is being you know the
borders being handled right now with
biden versus how it was handled prior to
him with trump
yeah yeah i think it's early in his
presidency his policies haven't really
been fully implemented
and the last thing he wants is a board
media down there
finding an angle and i don't think
there's much change that's gone down on
there
you know there hasn't been time to and
so he doesn't want the
media to go down there because now any
kids remember the terrible thing we
would see kids in basically
not little small detention apartments or
holding things but they look like cages
it was terrible
um it was terrible and it started under
previous president
i don't think he wants anybody down
there you know taking pictures because
this is now his problem you're the
president
so even if you didn't start it it
becomes your problem and you gotta
fix it and you gotta finish it oh that's
what the sound is this entire time i've
been thinking it's the mic it's the way
tom's speaking
that's what you're doing i'm calling
these guys out there like i'm telling
you it's not the mic it's time
okay all right so i'm relieved tom thank
you for that
that that that
thank you for distraction so we'll go
back to what i said i don't think biden
wants him down there taking pictures and
doing things because now he's the
president so he has to bring the
solution
they'll put it on him that's not what he
what do you think about a matter you
know i'm
from the perspective of my friend craig
sawman sawyer is a former navy seal
and he's there at the border all day
he's seen a huge spike
in people jumping aboard a huge spike
and sadly a huge since his big thing too
is also
preventing human trafficking huge spike
in human trafficking too as well
so so it's it's it's it's more now than
it was during when when trump
was controlling the border he's saying
it's more now than more now than it was
why do you think that is well you know
there's there's a lot of factors going
into you know
and again i'm again from my perspective
of what my family had to do to get here
from the philippines it was it was a
it was a recruitment into the nursing
program for my mother to get here
to say i'm going to be a nurse to be
recruited into the united states
and then our other family members
there's a five-year waiting period
10-year waiting period
for them to get here to the united
states from the philippines versus
people just come here to the border
and because of these uh these loosened
uh
policies to say hey we just come here
we'll campaign we'll get
we'll get across we'll get across to
find a way to get here kind of bully the
way and kick down
kick down the uh the gate kick down the
door um
you know i i don't know why it's it's
it's getting to that point but uh
it's a huge influx of that you know from
from a practicality standpoint
which would become biden's problem
because now he's the guy in the chair
blame your predecessor blame whoever you
want but now you're the guy in chair you
got to fix it right yep
yep you know again this is uh
this is not going to go away meaning i
don't think even the
liberal media is going to let them go
with this without holding them
accountable to it because
there are a lot of people in the liberal
media who are latinos and latinos who
are going to want to be
seeing what's going on because their
loyalty is to their community and if
they don't ask those questions about
what's going on with their community
their own people going to be like how
come you're not
holding the president accountable i
think that's a great point i think
that's a great point what do you think
it took so long i'm sorry tom
no i think that the you know the the
media
is not in a locked lockstep with biden
they really wanted him elected but
they're not in lockstep with him there's
a civil war inside
you don't think so no way i think
there's a civil war inside the
democratic party with bernie over here
and i also think there's a civil war
that's going on inside the media
between the people that are being told
to be lap dogs and be nice and the
people that have got strong
viewpoints and they want to see change
such as i i have
deep respect versus people of hispanic
descent that are in the media they're
they're speaking up and want to see
change you want to see great benefits
come to these issues
and don't just want to be a lap dog on a
political party basis i have deep
respect for them and they're going to
speak up and they're going to make the
stories out of it
what do you think it took uh biden this
long to get an official press conference
you know you know the whole thing with
uh
he doesn't know how to handle himself in
public when they ask him questions there
was a couple times where you kind of
like
that was that was very weird he was
going and he's like
yeah so here's am i talking too much
and then lady helped him it's like let
me just ask my second question yeah
okay okay go ahead go ahead so that was
a little awkward i don't know if you
guys caught that or not it's very very
awkward another part was uh do i need to
go into more detail
okay i'll just stop right now yeah that
was a little awkward and then there was
another part
where uh uh he was going
off the co like one time he just read
what was on the card he just went like
this he's like
so what what i think we need to do is
he looked down for 30 seconds just
reading the card to answer the question
okay
but then there was another part where
he went speaking for 10 minutes and it
wasn't based off of
a card i was like that seemed reasonable
what he just said right there i actually
was tracking with him and he was given
stats and data and numbers and
here's what happened here so so i don't
think
he is where most people think he is i
don't think he is where most people
think he is where he is
you know uh uh what's the word they use
where
uh you know he can't remember
he's coherent not coherent there's
another ward but cogent and lucid
yeah so so i don't know if it's those
words that's a level above me with words
but uh
but i would say at a point where he can
process issues and communicate with
people
now why do i think he's not done a press
conference for a while
uh you know i just don't it's like
why does somebody play defense and make
a player go left
because they don't do well going left
right you don't do a dribbling to the
left so
you as the offensive player have to
figure out a way to get what to the area
of strength which is to the right
his strength is not public speaking at
all joe biden i don't know how many
trophies he won public speaking it's not
his strength it's definitely not so
if that's not the case you just have to
have other people doing the talking form
and not being him that's my thoughts pbd
a question for you on this tell me
buried in the middle of all this was the
announcement that
kamal harris our vice president is going
to lead the immigration effort
she's going to lead the border
investigation
and there's a lot of voices out there
that said that she wasn't
selected to be vice president he ended
up with her vice president that the
whole mechanism and the whole
say that one more time he was what she
was not supposed to she was not selected
by him to be vice president he ended
up with her vice president because the
whole democrat party apparatus was like
hey we got to have a woman show them
gonna color there's a lot of good
reasons for sure
so every little girl in america could
look up and say hey look i can become
vice president i can do that
that's very very positive but there are
forces out there to say hey
you know biden ended up with her he
didn't necessarily want her
and the best place to her there's now
voices saying hey is she being set up to
fail did you hear some of this yesterday
yeah
what do you think being said the
appointments that she was
yeah there's democrat voices that are
saying hey she shouldn't be in charge of
immigration
like this is a leadership issue you
should is she being set up to fail
i don't think she's being set up to fail
i just think she was selected by others
i don't think she was selected by biden
i agree with you there yep let me ask
you
do you think uh obama picked biden
let me ask a question a different way
let me ask a question this way here's a
better way of asking a question
what percentage of obama picking biden
was him so you can say
i think it's 70 30 obama or 50 50 obama
50 percent of dnc okay well i was i was
a a
freshman senator but i remember meeting
joe
good guy friendly guy effective in the
senate long tenure
and uh it was about sixty two and a half
percent my decision so you're you're
gonna say so you're gonna say majority
was obama's decision
i think madrid i think the majority was
obama's decision but he was heavily
influenced because he was walking into a
room he'd never been before this is a
freshman senator
i i think okay let's say 62 percent is
what you're what would you say
i was going to say 75 25. oh so you
think it's him picking on the fight
no the other way okay how about you go
to uh uh trump
do you think he picked pence or do you
think somebody else picked pence for him
i think somebody else picked pence for
him what do you think is a percentage
with him and pence i
i would say the same percentage because
who can really uh be the parent in the
room when it come when it came to trump
okay what do you think tom pence uh i
think pence was a safe vanilla choice he
got a lot of
help doing but i don't think anybody
tells donald trump
what to do so so okay so you're saying
uh 90
trump 10 percent whoever told him that
these are your options
okay i can see that you need an ohio you
need an ohio indiana guy to balance it
off you're a new yorker let's get
another
video indiana midwest guy appealing
great choice by the way if you think
about it
christian guy not a lot of controversy
let's see if you can go with that donald
all right let me think about that okay
did bush pick his vp
george w george w what percent i think
the bush political family was well
established and i don't think they
needed help from the republican party
and i think they picked dick cheney for
a lot of reasons do you think he picked
it or the family picked dick cheney
i think he got a lot of help from papa
so what percentage was uh
was bush i think bush was probably about
25 percent
okay so so it's probably his dad okay so
clinton pick and gore who picked them
what percentage is bill clinton picking
gore um i think the same thing i think
democrat party said hey
you know you're southern you know this
guy's a good senator he's got more
experience than you do you're just a
governor remember he was just a governor
yeah
you get a guy from washington arkansas
so and then so you took this
neutral tennessee guy that didn't have a
lot of controversy gordon
remember people i i don't think in those
positions anybody
regardless of what party i don't think
the presidential candidate has much
of a selection of who the one is the
vice president i i think some
some is more than others i think
sometimes more than i fully believe some
is more than others
like i fully believe uh a you know
or what do you call it a reagan
is a guy that went in saying hey here's
kind of who i like
uh to be my guy and he was given
feedback by james baker with his options
and they sit there and they process it
and then he says here's who i'm picking
okay great so
and there's a lot of negotiation on
picking as well like when
kennedy picked lyndon johnson it was all
strategy because lyndon johnson
hated kennedy so kennedy wanted to get
rid of one of his biggest enemies his
number one enemy which is who
and the fastest way to turn an enemy
into an allies to what he will you be my
vp
right and he says i really don't want to
be your vp man you know the hell with
you i should be the president
you should even consider being my vp but
i get it let's make this work
and they needed texas so the electoral
vote math was there remember that thing
was close yeah so here's the magical
question
what percentage of biden
was him picking kamala yeah
twenty percent i disagree i totally
disagree
zero percent what do you think it was on
youtube the think it's the party i think
it's zero percent
biden pick and kamala yeah i i think and
the reason why
it's zero percent is because biden
didn't win the election
the party did correct biden didn't win
the election
trump won the election okay bill clinton
won the election
if you think about that bush the party
i i i don't know if i'm making sense
yeah right so there was a campaign yeah
clinton was a beast right yeah i also
think
obama had a lot of same pick and biden
because obama won the election
when obama ran for office don't forget
everybody was banking on who
hillary to win okay they weren't saying
obama's going to win it was like hillary
is going to win so
obama won that election so whoever wins
the election
i feel has more of a say on who becomes
every p
than the party versus whoever whatever
party wins it and they choose the
candidate
the party chooses who's going to be your
vp i think biden was zero percent him
choosing
kamala biden was just told kamal is your
vp
what do you think the percentage of
somebody picking a vp just to get over
the finish line
or versus somebody that would be good
fit for them for the four years
okay so if you go back and think about
who the vp candidates were for
uh for uh uh biden who were some of the
ones that were good candidates
uh do you remember the names rice
exactly who else
okay if you have a choice between susan
rice and kamala hurts who do you go with
are you 50 50 yeah i'm probably 50 50
because i'm not really a big fan of
either one of them
um you know minnesota what are a great
choice
minnesota would have been a great choice
okay yeah minnesota or michigan
no minnesota oh menace oh i'm sorry i
thought you said the uh
yeah that's that's what i thought you
said uh i thought tulsi would have been
an
amazing they would have never picked
tulsi because tulsi says what's on her
mind
they wouldn't have you're asking me yeah
as an american i would look there and
saying
you know veteran leading estate even
though it's why
i i would have admired that choice
yeah so to go back to it when you're
asking a question about kamala harris
do you hear about what kamal harris did
yesterday like working on
women and women empowerment you know who
he she reached out to for advice
who's that bill clinton wow what
is that confusing or what am i the only
one that's have you guys seen this or no
can you pull up kamala harris asked bill
clinton for advice and the media flipped
out
like she she's just put bill clinton
watch this here watch this year kamala
harrison bill clinton touting girl
empowerment
okay can you like that just makes no
sense by the way
and kamala harrison bill clinton touting
girls empowerment together is a bad
joke which news news baby which news by
the way this is nbc
correct why can't the democratic party
quit the former president if the party
is truly going to welcome women
it has to get rid of the political
milestone around its neck
millstone around this thing so i just i
just don't understand
why that's just so confusing
does that look good for the party by the
way no frankly i'm glad that any woman
calls me anymore you know
closing in on 80 here of course i put
that video in there
you know but the clinton affair by the
way this is
nbc putting this out this is not like
anybody else putting this out there
right so
this isn't drudge or fox here no no
that's that's nbc
can we see can we see what was what the
cnn said about the headline here go go
to different headlines just go back
cnn would say so what did fox news say
so okay president
okay now go back go back fox is gonna
say just go back to where you were
before
kamala harris to a whole discussion with
bill clinton on empowering women and
girls okay foxness is actually very
neutral nbc news took this shot this is
a bad joke
market watch kamala harris and bill
clinton are holding the talk about women
empowerment can you kind of go to what
the rest of the line is
q uh uh uh
by that oh they don't even have it here
how funny is that everything we put in
the search doesn't come down in the news
none of it matches the new did you see
that go back and go back and do that
again
yeah no no what does that have to do
with what we
searched interesting wait go wait i'm
confused here
this is google we have to search kamala
harris asks bill clinton for advice we
click on news
none of the links that come up is about
what you searched on google
the google algorithm doesn't seem to
want america to see the clinton story do
that
go back up go back up to all okay i
guess now try
okay use the same exact copy paste
exactly what you have and go to yahoo
it's kind of interesting many search
engines are
i'm curious let's see what they say here
just copy paste
okay vp slater 101 with bill clinton the
blaze okay so the blaze is at the top
fair enough they put the blaze at the
washington examiner rose mcgowan asked
if kamala harris has a soul
wow do you even have a click on that
click on that click on that
actress and feminist rose mcgonagall
after agreeing to obscene event with
bill clinton on empowering women wow
that's not good guys these are all the
people that defended clinton
you have to keep them there well no rose
mcgowan if you know who she is she's uh
um this is obscene kamala harris you
speaking with bill clinton about
empowering women and girls is disgusting
have you no soul
have you no ethics ask him about being
on an island of human trafficking
victims 27 times you're showing us
exactly who you are
go back go back and let's see what other
sites we'll see you know as i analyze
that from rose mcgowan
i have a a small sense that's kind of
growing on me that she's upset
scolding lower goal and lower goal the
lower goal
okay davideike.com comes up well you got
to be kidding me okay
hell was he doing look at that right so
you know
so i i don't know
the question i would have is who the
hell is advising them right now
that's what i'm asking so you have a
meeting and you say i'm thinking about
putting a girl in power in a meeting
together oh you should call bill clinton
by the way you should be a writer do you
know how the media knows this huh the
media knows this because every day
you know there are agendas that are put
out for the potus
what's potus doing today in the media's
given agenda he will be here going here
and then there's things they leave up
the agenda and they get criticized
because there is a billion dollar donor
that was at the white house during that
half hour you know you're talking about
map
so now sure the vice president united
states agenda
had that on it the only way they find
out about this is either clinton leaks
it
or it was already on the activity agenda
that's given to the media so they can
cover the uh
president vice president it's common
sense so it means that to your point
who's advising them there's also
somebody in there yeah yeah we'll put
the clinton thing on there what's the
worst that could happen
if there's any criticism if she wanted a
private conversation with bill clinton
could she have it
private meaning just make a phone call
nobody knows you're talking to correct
absolutely
sure so wait you're saying somebody set
them up is what you're saying no no i'm
saying that
her team you're asking who's advising
and i'm like that instinct i think is
absolutely correct here because her
daily agenda that's released to the
media
if i was her advisor i would say you
know you shouldn't put straight
call on there have a private phone call
get political
you know advice from him on how to
manage these situations
but for the love of god i mean what
advice could he give what advice could
he really give her
so spin it actually actually think your
kamala and spin it
spin it i'm a media i'm asking and i'm
not i'm not saying be funny about it
i'm not being comical i'm actually
saying spin it
spin it and say hey uh vice president
kamala here is
out of all the people you could have
chosen to speak to about a matter of
women empowerment
you have oprah winfrey you have uh you
know
uh michelle obama you have uh you know
even hillary hillary clinton you have
susan rice you have
you have you have a number of women to
go to you have daughters
yeah vice president come on harris
why why president bill clinton with the
reputation that he has
i don't know how to spin it because i
don't know why with that list you just
made
he would be number 87 on my political
advice
1000 million 87 so
but how do you actually try to spend
that one how do you spend that one i
think it was just incredibly bad
judgment
tom that can't that i don't buy that i i
don't buy that because
i i have a hard time buying that i have
a hard time buying
well he's the sh he is a shrewd
politician and very smart strategically
politically
but still the consequence is this that
we just saw
you know nbc sub headline what the hell
was she thinking
i was you know that's confusing to me if
you ask me yeah
all right let's go through some of the
folks here that have been commenting and
i've not come to you i'm going to come
to you right now
i'm freaking befuddled yeah this is this
is just entertaining for me when i'm
hearing this i'm i'm trying to figure
this out and that doesn't make any sense
to me okay
i'm just choking heat and i'm getting
pissed off about it okay
the ms uh miss maroon
50 she said i've been working from home
since last april and feel much more
productive and stressed of
the stress of being stuck in traffic is
no longer there the traffic in toronto
is horrible by the way great feedback
okay
so traffic i don't disagree with her on
so to her the value is the traffic
creates stress i want to go
and work from home and be productive
find the question then becomes
uh miss maroon would it be a fair
assessment to assume that you're a
teacher
if no please let us know i'm curious
what your occupation is
on uh on working from home or not
working from home
uh uh uh this year orodel noel zenitrman
said every bitcoin transaction is
already tracked and traceable it's going
to be about control
equals tax manipulation et cetera okay
and that by the way that's sniff it's
about to lead to the parody with our
friend
a guy that did the parody we're gonna
watch here together i told him i'm gonna
watch it it's gonna be reaction i have
not yet seen it
you saw it yesterday we're gonna have
you seen it yet or you haven't seen the
entire thing yeah
he's good i saw a part of the parade for
the funny sound
no but i'm doing sniffing myself that's
right
i'm not i'm not blaming you for the
funny sound no one makes more funny
sound than me
i mean i got a parody about me sniffing
i was thinking the system was broken i'm
chewing these guys out being texting
them
but okay all right let's go through it i
understand you're the source
but shared hotel rooms over 20 years
time they don't make me go there with
your source of sounds
if we go to the source of sounds it's
going to be a bad day for you buddy 2
a.m i thought there's a truck it's going
to be a bad day
for you okay all right the more they try
to go against bitcoin the more they
legitimize its use
case it's a win for bitcoin and kryptos
no matter what okay then we have smart
training 360
65 bio mechanics gave 20 i've been
trying to contact you for weeks your
support team is very helpful but i need
to speak with you directly any one
minute of your time
i have a suggestion of a business
proposition it's worth it david one
minute here's what i suggest you do why
don't you make a video
for one minute send it to me if it makes
sense i'll call you just so you get
this makes sense to you i get hundreds
of emails every day and quite frankly
it's challenging for me to do that
but make your one minute video i'll
commit to watching your one minute video
if it makes sense i'll get back and
can i add something there and sir go
find the guy kawasaki
10 page business plan exactly ten page
summarize it and send it with your one
minute video there we go okay so then we
have good mother gave another ten
dollars she said biden administration
said they won't turn away children
parents now enticed
to traffic their kids not good who is
going to take care of these kids
very good point because exactly these
kids are coming with a number there
you're calling the number the number is
not necessarily going to the parents
it's going to the trafficker
then they're sitting there the coyote
and they're sitting there saying who do
we call how do we get ahold of the
parents they don't know how to get ahold
of their parents
and uh they're they don't necessarily
know how to handle many of these things
over there then last but not least
pbd ten dollars from mr clean bald guy
what a phenomenal name mr clean ball guy
pbd do you think they couldn't give
biden some sort of a drug to just kind
of
give him a boost for an hour when he
visits like a local plant a
parent teacher conference has more
energy in the room so let me talk to
this guy here i got something to tell
you mr clean ball guy
and i hope you take this feedback i give
you in the in the best possible way
and if it makes sense great if you don't
like it you can say whatever you want i
will take it as well
and receive it because i'm giving it to
you uh i had a call with one of my
very close friends let's call
this person that means a lot to me and i
spoke to this individual
and uh one minute is the vaccine
conspiracy theory another minute was
what they're doing this another minute
was
another conspiracy theory another minute
was another conspiracy
30 minutes i heard 10 different
conspiracy theories
and i i paused this person i said can i
ask you a question and say what
i said the i said you know all the stuff
you said i've read about
okay where are you going with this i
said i've read about all these
conspiracy theories as well
i said when you read about all these
conspiracy theories and you know you go
down the rabbit hole yeah what about it
how long do you get stuck in that rabbit
hole oh a long time you know a long time
one
hour two hours that's okay is it really
only one hour or is it a week
a month a year two years what does it do
to you then here's my other question for
you
are you more tolerable to be around are
you more paranoid
are you more you know you know annoying
yourself because your brain cannot stop
working you lack sleep you have anxiety
a panic all this other stuff
yeah i do have all of that i said then
maybe
you read the conspiracy theories that
you're reading
but if you can't go if you're not
willing to commit your life
to fixing that conspiracy theory then go
live your life
i don't know if this makes sense or not
look all of these conspiracy theories
you read about
they're so entertaining tom you okay
okay you gotta use the wrestling uh
nature's ah snitches
it's the first time
[Laughter]
put the camera put the camera right here
this is the first
we got to get tom by the way
hey hey brooker brooker his daughter if
you're listening yeah i think your daddy
uh and these depends
uh uh here's what just happened right
now
this the joke was that only adam would
do this
only adam would do this but that empty
chair is our buddy biz doc thomas
ellsworth one of the greatest human
beings i know my life
had to go on a bio break so what we need
to do is we need to put a checklist
moving forward before we start use the
bathroom has to be added to the
checklist
okay just think about it he what he's
right hey by the way if you've been
mentored by patrick but david you
already know if you've been doing this
for years you already got the golden
bladder
we build muscle we build muscles there
ourselves
what we do you know to be mentored by
pvd you got to hold it down by the way
what the hell were we talking about
what were we talking about prior to this
conspiracy conspiracy
let me go through this with the
conspiracy theory deal this is very
important
and a lot of people have to really uh
consider this for themselves
if you you have a hard time staying
focused right now if
if you if you are willing to do
something about it
go for it meaning so you know how hey
i'm gonna go
fix human trafficking because i've read
every single article on it and i'm gonna
go out there myself and i'm gonna go
contribute
perfect go be read every single one of
them more power to you
but if you're somebody that reads one oh
my gosh you're doing this reason
oh my gosh they're doing this reason oh
my gosh they're doing this and you go
too much down the rabbit hole
without the ability to want to make an
impact it's just it's consuming your
life and it's not making you productive
you may want to minimize the amount of
time you give and credence you give to a
lot of conspiracy theories you read
don't go too deep into it some people
are going to say that's how you hold
people accountable this is why
people get away because somebody like
you says a comment like this i didn't
tell you i don't
uh uh i look away i don't tell you i sit
there and i say we shouldn't do
something i didn't tell you any of that
stuff
all i'm saying is some people it ruins
their lives their marriage their
relationship the way they do do business
the way they parent
i can't see i can't tell you how many
people i've seen go down the rabbit hole
of conspiracy
theories actually ruin their lives yeah
absolutely if you're if you're not
willing to commit to fix any issue
you're not willing to complain against
it
raise awareness uh but if you are there
just like a pinball and a pinball
machine and you're getting smacked
everywhere it's it's a rough place to be
playing defense your entire life you
feel better tom
i feel much better comes back in the
studio
this is a real company you're giving me
a bottle that i can pee in under the
tutorial
no no just like amazon they give those
uh empty coke bottles to all their
drivers so they can pee in them while
they're uh
you're being serious yeah yeah i mean
thomas by the way
you officially took the entire
part that was given to adam away from
him so adam if you're listening to this
you are no longer the guy that we joked
about
first podcast coming late because you
were using a bathroom that officially
has been given
to tom moving forward okay so we've
covered a lot now
i'm so sorry why why don't we do this
why don't we do this so
i get i get a i get a message i get a
message from a guy saying hey did you
see this guy that did the parody of you
i said what are you talking about what
parody i'm listen i've seen a lot of
parodies
they've done a lot of paradise of me
they make fun of the accent they make
fun of my look
all this stuff but i actually thought
this guy did a great job
when uh the reaction i get from uh uh
kai comes up this guy says hey pat
he said this and he shows me the first
15 seconds i said stop stop it right now
i said i like the stuff he's doing i
want to watch the whole thing let's do
reaction video and respond to him so
this is my first time watching it
i've only seen the first 15 20 seconds
can we watch it and pause and or do
you want to go through it or you want to
pause it i actually want to pause it
a couple times kai what do you think
okay then go through let's see what he
says here go ahead and we'll comment on
it
and we're off okay you need audio for it
to work hi
okay first of all you're always clean
with your suits i don't know why his uh
collar is on yeah
well we'll see what he's doing here
we'll see
most people only see the final product
for most people the successes the great
cars the honda crv
is the hardships the long years of
struggle the rejection
the knocking on doors and being held at
guns he's got a gun
let me explain stop explaining things
get out of my face
okay but say something cut it out okay
actually explain can you go set up for
the next mafia interview
you were actually interviewing a real
made man
yeah have you seen goodfellas
because i freaking love that movie do
you love that movie
you got rules to the game right because
what are the rules of seduction
you got to give them credit though did
you like the you know whiteboard
uh how do you double your money how do
you make that happen and i said let me
ask you a question
and they say you get the white t-shirt
he's missing the goat chain though
by the way go back this is so funny the
the way he's uh he's uh
doing uh how i explained the interaction
go back a few seconds young man we were
ordering the bottles a lot of people ask
me yo patrick uh how do you double your
money how do you make that it's got the
accent it's actually a question
they say well patrick i asked you a
question first and i said you know tag
you're it now
what are you going to do and so they say
well fine if you're going to force what
is every hair all
so basically you got one guy making 250k
you're making a quarter of a million
dollars a year
how much 2018. right there
just go back go back
matt we're going to talk about something
matt no hang on hang on
i was asking you that's it right there
keep going buddy
siri what's 24 times 36 the answer is
864.
see see that's why college is becoming
obsolete i sat my wife down the other
day look maybe we are committed for life
the court has to
there you go so there's nothing we can
do to come out of it because there's no
way you're getting half seven things to
do
one is marriage take your time with
marriage so i told my wife listen baby
we got to keep looking
good we have to keep looking good
because
oh here we go the sniffs here we go to
sniff do you want a tissue
no no i'm great i'm just i'm just
letting my enemies know that i'm a
competitor you know
it's supposed to startle you sharp
inhale through the nose
the sniff you see it in the animal
kingdom all the time the king gorilla
will just
kick around and i'm like oh my god what
is wrong with it
what do you mean let's talk about that
you worry about your game
executing on your plan there are
actually
uh six areas i want to discuss with you
guys that you've lived
first the story you know the story of
being a good fella i was thinking maybe
you and i we go in and we make a new one
called great fellows what do you think
you know
painted to be in the movies of course
you know i'm very lucky that i got out
alive so you're being a bit of a
right now you're not gonna
and um let me explain to you let me
explain to you what i mean you're a
okay okay he's about to try the ball
number one goal as an entrepreneur
right so basically you need to ask
yourself who is afraid who is
literally terrified for their health for
their lives for the family
and then how can i make money off of
this person you might think that i
follow you
let me explain let me explain to you
what i mean oh you think i'm funny no i
never said that like funny how funny
like a clown please don't get into this
the gangster life is not real you got an
income problem thomas
and that's why thomas
do you love boom peanut butter
friendly what happened kai a big thank
you to magic spoon for sponsoring this
video
what is this magic spoon story
it is oh really okay is it was it
canadian
all right so good for him by the way
nailed it
no i like what he did there's a uh in in
title his name is what's sinbad what's
his name captain sinbad captain sinbad
great job
good for you watch his valuetainment
once he watches valuetainment once and
does this so there you go i commented i
said
i haven't seen it yet but the reaction
will be coming soon pbd here's a
reaction video so you got it funny by
the way
you know last night we were at the house
and you guys are sitting there watching
this cracking up
and this is your second time watching
this but last night we were watching uh
uh adam watched uh john mason's uh
reaction video
years ago have you seen that one john
mason did a good one i've seen many of
them but
nine years ago yeah he was he was
hilarious when he did that as well john
john can do me better than i can to me
is how good he is with it
okay all good well sinbad uh you're
hilarious
i just realized every time moving
forward i sniff i want to be thinking
about you just so you know we have a
relationship for the rest of our lives
with this sniffing situation okay um
let's see what we got here to go through
okay boom boom boom
okay let's talk about sue's canal i
think that's a very important issue to
cover here
so enormous container ship got stuck in
the suez canal
blocking one of the world's most vital
shipping routes okay
a massive cargo ship just to kind of put
in perspective how big this thing is
bigger than the eiffel tower bigger than
the statue of liberty
bigger than the empire empire state
building that's how big this thing is
it's a quarter mile long container that
is ridiculous how big this thing is
so i just on business insider for every
hour
it's estimated that it's costing 400
million
per hour per hour's is costing 400
million dollars so if you're wondering
how
uh uh wondering how a ship that weighs
220 000 tons
and is the size of an empire state
building ended up sideways canal
officials say high winds from a
sandstorm restricted visibility around
the time
the ship got stuck the location on the
ground it couldn't have been wasted so
as canal is vital but narrow
link in many global supply chains and
delays there reverberate
around the world around 10 of worldwide
shipping traffic flows through its
narrow waters including
roughly five percent of global traded
crude oil no one is shocked this
happened the swiss canal is only 300
feet wide shipping companies uh
usually factor in extra days to their
schedules to account for any unexpected
delays but if it ever if the
ever given clogs the canal for
longer than that prices of stranded
cargo from crude oil to consumer good
could be affected tom what do you think
about this
i think we've got an outdated canal
there you know
that nobody wants to pay to make any
bigger
and i i think it's just really really
unfortunate you know there's nothing
controversial i see about this other
than
man this is this canal was built when
you know
and it's never been significantly so
okay so
but there's there is a comment there if
that's what you're saying what you're
saying is the world ought to come
together put a budget to fix the canal
if the world can come together and put a
budget to fix the canal that doesn't
become a one person
whoever participates and benefits from
it why don't we reinvest in it is that
kind of what you're saying
yeah you know you take a look at the
panama canal and the suez canal just
take a map
of the globe and say you need those two
you need those two points to get
stuff shipped from here to here i think
there would be an issue with that though
because there's a toll they pay
for going through the canals at that
point i'd say if i'm a captain
just we're paying you to go through this
we're paying you to use this road why
don't you fix it that's your problem
it's the toll roads in new england suck
they're all full of potholes all those
tolls just go to the state to your point
it should be used for maintenance and
improvement but
we have a lot of examples on toll roads
around the world that don't
three to five million uh barrels of oil
per day are held back
so that's gonna spike up gas prices uh
uh yeah carrying jet fuel and gasoline
gasoline
oil is a gasoline
and we'll go to the sewers canal right
here egypt
yeah i think the white i think it's uh
they were saying is like 300 feet wide
at one point
you got to be kidding me yeah yep so
it's very
tiny oh my gosh yeah and they all have
to stage
they stage their are you kidding me that
little change there'll be a thing yeah
wait right there
that little thing right here
are they are they able to fix it or not
yet are they making progress
stuck and the thing is the way the boat
is built
it has like a bow on the front that is
good for weather but that one has
literally dug into the ground so they
need to
like dig in they got a dredge in there
talking about the other part is they got
to start
unloading containers somehow on other
ships so that it'll
become lighter and they can readjust it
you're going to unload it it's going to
be interesting get some cranes out there
ship the ship exactly yeah so this so
they're saying that this can take
days if not weeks to get rid of it which
obviously is gonna clog a whole lot of
global trade
and there's talks that they'll be
similar to you know how with the
pandemic
outages in the supply chains because
the only option would be for companies
to send their boats
around uh the
horn of africa come up which is
quite the detour and quite the detour i
mean that's just that's ridiculous
and it's uh heavy weather down there too
there's heavy weather at cape horn it's
like saying there's no panama canal same
thing in the city
take a look at the gulf of mexico see
all those red dots physically
go physically to what it looks like i'm
sorry go ahead tom you were saying no so
you we'll get back to that a second
let's go take a look at the
there's this amazing picture of the
stuck ship with this little tiny looks
like a lego crane sitting next to it
digging in the sand look how sideways it
is there it is there you see that so as
canal dredging firm
take a look at that kai uh right nope
right next to it on the right down right
there look at that that's an enormous
tractor look at this
they're digging this out order of a mile
ship yeah and it looks like a little
lego doesn't it just like
down there this is not the question is
how often does this happen
how often does it say sandstorms happen
all the time first time
but uh for that to be ground that way
what do they call it
who gets held accountable for something
like this who's accountable for
something like this this is a pretty big
screw up the world is
i mean the economy is affected by it
first certain industries are affected by
it who's held accountable for this
well outside of the captain uh you got
to look at the the shipping company
the shipping company you got to look at
the the port the canal controls
so uh this morning brew actually had a
good good comment regarding the the
the trip it's like driving from new york
to philadelphia
via calgary via calgary
yes and it is 6 000 miles
and three hundred thousand dollars in
fuel costs to the journey
of going around versus through wow
so things uh this is a prob possibly a
justification for again gas prices go up
fuel prices go up
other things that this suez canal ships
to other manufacturers for goods and
services that go up
were you looking at the source canal
stuff or yeah so
basically you've got two choices um
choice number one is you reroute things
choice number two
freaking world comes together and
figures out how to offload some of the
stuff make it
lighter and then you need that's a giant
tractor there you need
[Music]
it's just like you need like 10 of those
this
this ship is the size of a country the
japanese owner for skyscraper size cargo
ship
issues an apology we're extremely sorry
for
causing tremendous worry to the ships
that are traveling our scheduled traffic
and suez canal and all the related
people
you missed the first word oops we're
very sorry
damn gina let's see what he missed it's
like the exxon valdez remember
you know whether he was asleep or drunk
remember that it's like louie wake up
what you hit a state
and this it's just not going to take a
few hours a few days this takes a few
weeks
for this to get fixed yep
cargo between asia and uranu ground
tuesday man-made canal dividing
continental africa
and the sinai peninsula
it all went sideways
okay so last topic to talk about before
we wrap up here
um uh i'm looking at twitter kyle you
seen any questions for us to go to or
you've seen any questions for us to go
to because i'm looking
i want to get the twitter crowd we get a
couple of questions here to wrap up with
uh you know something else going on in
the twenties okay towards mine the
jealousy if i didn't join the senate 120
years ago
so funny people love taking shots at our
buddy biden here okay so
what are your numbers okay if you guys
got any questions posted there but we're
going to wrap up here with the royal
caribbean story royal caribbean just
announced more fully vaccinated cruises
this year this time in the mediterranean
royal caribbean just unveiled a new
summer series of fully vaccinated
cruises and mediterranean
only one day after it announced a
different loca collection of
vaccine-mandated sailings from bermuda
vaccinated against covet 19 and craving
a warm summer escape a broader cruise
ship
royal caribbean's newly announced seven
night mediterranean cruises may be a
good fit for you
these new mediterranean sailings will
cruise with a vaccine mandate
this means all crew members and adult
guests abroad the ship
will have to be vaccinated against covet
19 while passengers under
18 years old will instead have to test a
negative
for the virus however royal caribbean
notes that these protocols may change as
they are evaluated
on an ongoing basis thoughts well
we uh we were participants in a royal
caribbean cruise line a couple years ago
we went to mediterranean went to uh
islands a beautiful trip
um i remember when covet first hit they
wouldn't let that uh
that cruise ship come aboard uh and and
as much
as people were hesitant about jumping on
a plane
will you trust and physically trust your
body in the
in a cruise liner for seven days four
days five days where you're around
everybody you eat everywhere
you're together it's going to be
interesting how the social distance is
going to take place
especially in the buffet when it's food
time or times go show or time to get
in line for onboarding onboarding
debarking process
i think they're just trying to get back
in business baby yeah they're just
trying to get back in business and one
way to do it is okay if you're all
vaccinated come on here we'll go on a
trip
because remember there were three
crisises at the beginning of cobit right
crisis number one what exactly is this
virus what do we do about we just didn't
know the biological makeup of it
second crisis is what you know it's is
this it the wuhan food court
the what the what meat market or was it
you know a lab over there there was the
china conspiracy
and then the next big story was the
first two
before we were using the word super
spreader we had two cruise ships
that were basically stuck was it uh
washington no no no no no no they ended
up in san francisco but they were stuck
in
tokyo weren't they like tokyo harbor
that the cruise ships at the very
beginning of covet
and cruise ships have never had a
reputation for being perfectly clean
people talk about the water and food
poisoning and things like this
so i think they're just trying to get
back in business and they're saying this
is where we're going to do it
i think is that something get some
revenue coming in yeah the pritzker
family owns
the illinois governor jim jimbo pritzker
um 55th richest man in the world the
government that family
owns the royal caribbean you know it's
uh
it's going to be interesting travel i i
think with what we
experienced just coming down here to
boca flying at fort lauderdale just to
see the explosion of
of rental cars and businesses and people
coming down here i think the same thing
potentially going to happen here with
cruise line people
there's a the parties you were talking
about the person wants us to stay home
a person's okay around other people and
the third person said i'm fine just
being out and about they're ready to go
who who has the most
uh influence the radical uh
who is like dude i don't really care
whether i wear a mask or not
the radical who is extremely paranoid
don't get near me don't touch
me you know this is we're being foolish
state of texas being irresponsible for
getting people to go back to work this
is not the right thing to do
or the people in the middle who are like
let's just tell me what the rules and
regulations i'll follow it who has
the most more influence the most
influence for everybody to be scared
for their uh criticism of the other side
which of those three would you say it is
i think it's the one in the middle the
second one because they have the bigger
it's a broader base uh people that
aren't uh
you know they're okay with being amongst
other people and kind of let me know
what the rules are we'll follow
i think that's uh the folks with the
most influence what do you think
i think people started out scared and
then they were frustrated and now you
have vaccination that people think is a
panacea seal just let me remind
everybody we get vaccinated for the flu
every year because these viruses morph
you know they evolve um i think that the
seeing more people doing more normal
things with a vaccination
is a big peer pressure and raises and
drops people's guard to say
you know what honey we can go out now we
can go to dinner now i'm seeing more of
our friends do it they take a mass
they're very careful
but they're vaccinated and they're
getting back into it we can do that too
i think that's a very the pure around
you seeing them
to get back to normal we all want to get
i think that's fair
and i think i think that what do you
think guy
which of the groups have more influence
yeah uh i think the
the radical uh like don't care at all
no mask no crew um i think those are
obviously
everyone can look at them and call them
the crazy ones uh so in a sense i think
it's
more the not the middle but the the
hysterical ones
that's kind of where i'm at because
they'll play the victim card scream
scream the wolf so i definitely think
that and everybody's scared nowadays
walking on egg shows did you see what
this person said did you see what that
person said
yeah exactly i agree with you who's
doing that that's horrible yeah because
of xyz
i agree with you darryl okay final
thoughts matt any final thoughts on
urine or
tom anything you guys got you know my
final thoughts are
back with this whole uh new york pot
legalization it's interesting to see how
things have progressed over the years
where
you know especially being a parent
it's just uh it's just been interesting
for me as a journey as a dad trying to
raise my kids in this uh legalized
marijuana
type world exactly way too natural right
there yeah
way too natural right there i saw it
like experience i saw it in boogie
nights
yeah right you sounded almost famous
almost famous is where you saw it i am a
golden god
and my last thoughts is a gen z on
remote work i'm looking forward to a
hybrid model i think
people are waiting to get back into
connection with folks there's
there's going to be some people that
feel much more comfortable being
isolated i think for the majority of
folks out there waiting to get out yeah
i mean
just to see what people are doing here
flying into florida people are waiting
to connect again
i'm glad to see the johnson johnson uh
vaccine the one shot come out i'm glad
to see pfizer's doing well in america
with the two shot
um i'm glad to see more people getting
vaccinated and the more time that's out
there also means that the more
variants of the vaccine and the testing
that's going on
and to make that better i think that's
good and i'm glad that american business
is sensibly in many cases since very
sensibly
trying to get back going and get that
people back to work and um
i'm impressed with the resiliency of
america just this past week and the
things i've seen
and i also traveled down here i traveled
from dallas so i agree with your
comments about travel and people getting
back to it
i disagree with all those you know
people that
were just super spreading down in miami
not the way to do it
have some brains man shout out to uh
corrupted fifty dollars pvd and crew
your thoughts on usn fighting with each
other like
we're gang members blue and red when in
reality it's china who's the enemy
for interrupting but congratulations
buddy i really
got what we got what's up saucy i get a
did you see that that was impressive
watching it live i was like this can't
be happening
ran off by the way didn't even hesitate
well i mean you are free officially adam
you are free i hope you think tom maybe
take him out to chipotle or something
yeah this is good man this is fantastic
i think it's actually an emotional
moment for you it's actually probably an
emotional moment for you
with this emotion
the golden bladder award for those of
you that witnessed
history being made today with tom
ellsworth this is the first time ever
in 48 episodes somebody's done that
history it went
officially in the history books records
are being made and broken
and today's record was broken by mr
thomas ellsworth
first two first two that's right we're
big on first two it's huge on first time
we're big on first twos we like first
two
you're amazing adam let me tell you're
amazing for coming out and
and giving out shout out to tom gang if
you're watching this if you enjoyed it
the
last 50 dollars came from yimi mourinho
you guys are great i highly recommend my
friends to watch your podcast and videos
start to read the book my son and i also
listen to the videos when i'm driving
phenomenal thank you for that gang if
you enjoyed today's podcast
click that subscribe button help us get
to 100 000 subscribers
and i think we're doing this again next
tuesday tuesday nine o'clock
again put it in your calendar we'll see
you there take care everybody bye bye
bye bye bye
thank you man thanks tom thanks
you